graduation day it has never been like
this don't you know tech investor and
philanthropist Robert Smith erase a
burden of student loan debt for the
entire 2019 class entire class at
Morehouse College mark Strassmann is at
the school in Atlanta with how one
graduate plans to pay it forward mark
this is so big good morning to you good
morning Gail yes like all private
colleges let's face it the Morehouse is
expensive all in this historically black
school cost $48,000 but for every member
of this year's graduating class a
billionaires surprise gift means they
can chase their dreams instead of their
death on behalf of the eight generations
of my family who have been in this
country we're going to put a little fuel
in your bus more helps college graduates
received way more than their diplomas on
Sunday this is my class 2019 billionaire
commencement speaker Robert Smith
dropped a 40 million-dollar surprise
stunning students and school
administrators and my family is making a
grant to eliminate their student loans a
[Applause]
promise to pay off every penny of their
student loans Smith is the founder and
CEO of a private equity firm according
to Forbes magazine he's worth an
estimated five billion dollars just
imagine the weight lifted off your
shoulders when you have a clean slate
coming out of college and Dwight Lewis
just graduated from Morehouse with a
degree in Business Administration he
danced his way across the stage after
learning his student debt was wiped away
more than $150,000 there's an
overwhelming feeling in a good way and
it's just like I'm so motivated to go
change the world the 21 year old from
Compton California used to be homeless
and often didn't know where his next
meal was coming from let alone how he
would one day pay for college like wow
okay I'm going into a few hundred
thousand dollars a day right and then
your last 30 seconds of being an
undergrad student someone tells you I'm
taking the burden of your student loan
go change the world
Smith's generous gift comes at a time
when
and loan debt has soared to roughly
one-and-a-half trillion dollars the
average student loan debt is more than
$33,000 Lewis says Smith's gifts
motivates him to help others who
struggled just as he did it is room for
you in this world you can do what you
want to do you can't follow your dreams
and I think that's where it starts I
think once you have that mindset of I
want to be impactful and I want to
change the world I promise you that
energy just transpires the total value
of all the individual loans and of
Smith's gift is still being calculated
in return Smith says he expects
recipients to pay it forward and it
challenged alums here to give future
classes
the same opportunity and advantage
Anthony mark thank you incredibly
generous but as was pointed out by mark
it's like this is a huge problem it's
bigger bigger than credit card debt in
this country you know we can't rely on
billionaires to bail everybody out it's
got it's got to be addressed but Bravo
to Robert Smith who did it so calmly and
just so matter-of-fact and you can see
the happy dance that that guy was doing
upon dancing incredible relief in this